Happened again.
Another wild airline incident this time
A fight breaking out
between two passengers
on a Southwest flight
just before takeoff.
One man putting the other in a h
calling him obscenities
before punches were thrown at hi
A passenger on the flight
tells CNN
the man in the tan
jacket said the other man
approached his family
aggressively, offered
to help.
Tell us what you can get for tha
right now.
Sit down and gel with you.
Approach him off
before we go from our family.
So that's a bit short.
So let's get perspective on this
Ed Lavandera live for us in Texa
Ed, good morning.
This video finally gives us
a full picture
of what happened on this flight.
What can you tell us
Good morning, Don.
Well, things clearly escalated q
All this happened
before the plane
even left the gate here
at Dallas Love Field on Monday.
And as you mentioned there,
according to the witnesses, spok
with CNN and had to
it had to do with an altercation
oh, one of the passengers
who was receiving the punches
bumping into the other man's fam
And the witness also said
before the video even
started recording there,
there were three
or four different punches alread
before that video even picked up
So some tense moments there
before that flight even left the
Southwest Airlines
said in a statement that it comm
the actions of its crew
and for
resolving the situation
and also ensuring the comfort
of other passengers on the plane
And this is
they also went on to say
that the flight took off.
It arrived on time.
It was a flight
scheduled to leave
from Dallas left
field to Phenix on Monday.
But clearly,
a great deal of tension now
as spring break travelers
start filling up
airports across the country.
A reminder
that even though airplanes are f
tensions are also high.
And the Dallas police department
what are they saying
You know, both men were
taken off the plane.
They left the plane
and no charges were filed.
Dallas police told us yesterday
that no charges were filed.
None of the neither of the men
were arrested.
So where exactly they ended up
if they caught another flight?
We don't we don't exactly know.
But that flight did take off.
But no, no
criminal charges
being filed in this particular c
Ed Lavandera in Dallas. Thank yo